Балтійське узбережжя Німеччини.
Приморський курорт Любмін.
Тут труби газопроводу "Північний потік"
загальною довжиною 1200 кілометрів
виходять на сушу, і газ із Росії закачується
в європейську газотранспортну систему.
Це новий маршрут із Сибіру до Західної Європи,
який веде в обхід України. Експерт із експорту газу
Гайко Ломанн переконаний: в цьому і полягала
мета "Газпрому" - обійти Україну.
- Російська сторона постійно наголошує,
що "Північний потік-2", як і "Північний потік-1",
не має на меті обійти Україну.
Але мені здається, що саме ці проблеми,
які були в Росії з транзитом газу через Україну,
однозначно були вирішальним фактором
при будівництві "Північного потоку-1 і 2".
Це стара історія - конфлікти на пострадянському просторі.
Тут, на узбережжі Балтики, російський газ
закачуватиметься в новий трубопровід EUGAL
і йтиме в бік Чехії, а звідти -
до австрійського газового хабу Баумґартен.
Протяжність наземної ділянки - 580 кілометрів.
Будівництво вже майже завершене.
А от у сусідній із Німеччиною Польщі
будівництво нового газогону викликає
однозначно негативну реакцію.
Усі політичні партії країни виступають проти
поставок енергоносіїв із Росії. Із 2022 року Польща
планує повністю відмовитися від російського газу.
Зокрема й тому, що Москва використовує його
як інструмент тиску в зовнішній політиці.
- Ми платили по 400 доларів за тисячу кубометрів.
При тому, що Німеччина платить 260 доларів,
Австрія - 230, а Словаччина - 280.
Так нас карали за нашу прозахідну, пронатівську політику.
Ці кадри зняті за кілька кілометрів
від узбережжя Німеччини.
Це судно - трубоукладач.
Проти будівництва газопроводу виступають
не тільки Польща і країни Балтії, а й Сполучені Штати.
Вашингтон хоче запровадити санкції
проти компаній - підрядників будівництва.
Ще одна колишня радянська республіка - Литва -
теж має намір відмовитися від російського газу.
У порту Клайпеди розвантажують судно
зі зрідженим газом із Катару. Польща закуповує
сланцевий газ у США.
Зузанна Новак, польська експертка з газового ринку,
аналізує політичні наслідки запуску трубопроводу.
Вона вважає, що "Північний потік -2" ще більше розколює Європу.
- "Газпром" - і без того ключовий гравець
на європейському ринку, і якщо ми починаємо
закуповувати в нього ще більше газу, це означає,
що його домінуюча роль буде ще більше
посилюватися. Тобто Польща захищає не лише
свої інтереси, а й інтереси інших країн,
які виступають проти цього проекту.
До того ж, на тлі глобального потепління
противники газопроводу наводять ще один аргумент:
при спалюванні природного газу виділяється
той самий вуглекислий газ, емісію якого
всі так прагнуть скоротити. Експерти обговорюють
технології майбутнього - розщеплення
природного газу й отримання з нього водню.
- Якщо ми говоримо про довгострокове
використання природного газу, то треба говорити
про отримання водню з природного газу.
Саме в Росії ведеться робота
над цими технологіями, що дозволять
розщеплювати газ і отримувати з нього водень.
У принципі такі технології можуть дати можливість
отримання великої кількості зріджених енергоносіїв.
Якщо ці розробки будуть успішними,
то не виключено, що в майбутньому
цим газопроводом можна буде прокачувати водень.
Але навіть якщо проект стане екологічнішим,
політичні суперечки навколо нього не вщухнуть.